thank you very much we just completed a
very good meeting of the coronavirus
task force and we really they're really
doing a great job our professionals the
results are very very very good and when
you compare this to what's happening
around the world we're very proud of our
people there's been a tremendous amount
of coordination with States with cities
and they're a little smaller form of
government and they have things going
well they're coordinating with us and
certain in particular I think California
has been terrific the relationship New
York has been really good we've had some
really good relationships in terms of
especially the hot spots and we're
focused on those hot spots some areas we
have no problem whatsoever and we hope
to keep it that way yeah before I turn
this over to our great vice president to
provide an update I just want to express
my appreciation for the hard work done
by the people behind me and the people
back in the various offices including
the fact that I just left the Oval
Office so we have some people there that
are probably watching this or they're
just working we're using the full power
of the federal government to defeat the
virus and that's what we've been doing
last week we secured an initial eight
point three billion dollars from
Congress for the corona virus and that
was quickly done and very efficiently
done I want to thank all members of
Congress yesterday had declared a
national emergency which was a very big
deal because it opened up avenues that
we would never be able to open up
without it and it will make it more than
it'll make more than 50 billion dollars
available to us immediately in disaster
relief funds and that's available for
states territories and local governments
so that was really really good we also
reached an agreement yesterday on a new
legislative package
we'll provide strong support for
American families and communities in
dealing with the coronavirus so it was
done very very bipartisan it was it was
very nice to see it probably the
cooperation I wanted to thank Secretary
of Treasury statement urgent who did a
fantastic job and worked with Nancy
Pelosi and their representatives and it
was really great worked out very well
and a lot of people are benefitting by a
lot of a lot of provisions in the bill
which they're going to be discussing
with you today and the tremendous
provisions so that's something that we
should talk about I was honored to see
that the stock market you were mostly
there with us set a record in a short
period of time over a 45 minute period
that we had the press conference
yesterday in the Rose Garden that's it
that was a record all-time record I
think we should do one of them every day
perhaps how about every about five times
a day will do one five times a day yeah
but that was something to watch and I
had no idea we walked back I said so how
did that work out they said sir you just
said a new record in the history of the
stock market so that was pretty good and
those great companies that were there
they couldn't have been too unhappy
either when you think about it because
they're all very big publicly listed
companies so they did a good job and
more importantly they're going to do a
good job when you look at CBS and
Walmart and all of the tremendous people
that were there yesterday these are the
biggest and the best and they're opening
up their facilities that are opening up
there right now literally working right
now on opening doing something that's
never been done before to the extent
that we're doing it and so we're very
proud of them also the bill provides for
free coronavirus testing for all
americans who should be tested so people
that are getting tested are getting this
free they don't have to pay a lot of
people said gee it's a lot of money and
it is it's a you know it's a pretty
complex test actually and
it costs money and what it's being
provided free so people have to worry
about that it also provides paid sick
and family medical leave for those who
need it including for those who have the
virus for caregivers and those looking
after children affected by school
closures so that's all taken care of
also and we'll continue all of these
different actions we have other things
planned we're going to also be working
with companies that are affected
financially our country is in the best
financial shape we've so different in
the past over the years of you look at
some of the real big crises we had it
was financial problems and different
things we now are in very very strong
financial shape with all of the trade
and all of the other things that we've
been doing it's been pretty amazing
we hope the Federal Reserve will finally
get on board and do what they should do
because we're doing things that they
should be doing frankly and we could all
do them together but they should be much
more proactive other boards and other
countries and and people representing
those countries are taking a much more
aggressive action than our fed and for
the most part so we'd like to see the
you know if you look at central banks
yesterday what they did we want to see
our our Federal Reserve be much more
proactive it's important but in the mean
time we're doing things that that are
that have been really well received I
guess you saw that yesterday at the end
of the day with what we've done we have
a lot of things to tell you in terms of
respirators in terms of all of the
different things or the masks are being
made by the millions millions and
millions we have plenty now but we're
ordering for the millions we're ordering
worst-case scenario always we always say
worst-case scenario and that's where
we're going so I just want to thank
everybody I think the press has been
really over the last 24 hours I think
the representations really been very
fair for the most part it's been very
fair
we're all in this together it's
something that nobody expected it came
out of China and it's one of those
things that happen nobody's fault we all
we all will solve this problem will
solve it well I think the American
people have been incredible in the way
they've acted there's been and and and
if you look at companies and sports
leagues and all of the things what
they've done is is just something very
special without being told
necessarily in some cases perhaps they
were told actually but for the most part
they want to get it over with they want
to get it over with quickly and with
very little death as of this moment we
have 50 deaths which is a lot of good
decisions were made or that number could
be many times that that's based on a lot
of good decisions one or two in
particular you know that Europe was
declared the hot spot yesterday a big US
but and number one and and we we made a
decision quite a bit prior to that but
we saw what was happening but if you
have any questions this group will be
very happy to do it but I just want to
say they have been led by Mike Pence
they have been incredible the job they
do they're working 20 hours a day this
man is working 20 hours a day or maybe
more is it more I think that's more Tony
has been working I'm just looking at
this old group and we've created a
number of new stars including the
gentleman right behind me I watched him
the other day and such a fantastic job
you know and I really appreciate it but
they're gonna be answering questions and
and we have a lot of new information so
I think you'll find it very interesting
and I'll be going back to the Oval
Office thank you
mr. president there are so many people
right now they're rushing to Costco
they're rusted rushing to grocery stores
all the countries are filling up their
baskets is that the right move do you
think that people should actually be
saying you know maybe conserve as
opposed to buy also overnight Apple sir
they announced that they're gonna be
closing all of their stores for two
weeks do you want to see other retail
outlets or restaurant stuff like that do
the same thing I think it's fine if they
do it I think it's frankly it's good if
they do it I think what Apple did is
fine and want to keep people away for a
little while just keep them away and you
know when it gets better well people are
going and buying things and I understand
that by the way I had my temperature
taken coming into the room you did good
good well that means we're all looking
good you also took I also took the test
less and I decided I should based on the
press conference yesterday people were
asking that I take the test I don't know
whatever it takes a day or two days
whatever whatever it is they send it to
a lab hands with people yesterday you
have talked about five million tests
being available probably won't need that
many have your own sense of urgency
evolved and are you changing what you're
doing no I've been urgent this is urgent
for me if right from the beginning you
know that because I closed up our
country to China because it almost
becomes a habit and you get out of that
habit and frankly I was a non
hand-shaker for the most part I'd never
believe that shaking hands once you
become a politician and I noticed it too
political people walk up to me they want
to shake my hand I said well you know
just take a destiny COK just relax
people come up to me they shake hands
they put their hand out it's sort of a
natural reflex and we're all getting out
of it all of us have that problem
somebody comes up to you they put the
hand out you probably tend to just shake
it and we're all getting out of that
shaking hands is not a great thing to be
doing right now
agree but people put their hand out
sometimes I'll put the hand out you
don't think about it people are thinking
about it born well we have to think
about it it's important
somebody said yesterday I touched the
microphone I was touching it because we
have different height people and I'm
trying to make it easy for them because
they're gonna have to touch because it
wouldn't be able to reach the mic they
wouldn't be able to speak in the mic so
I'll move the mic down and they said oh
he touched the microphone well if I
don't touch it they're gonna have to
touch it somebody's gonna have to so I
might as well be the one to do it but no
we all have to get away from in getting
away from shaking hands is a good thing
and possibly that's something that comes
out of this maybe people shouldn't be
shaking hands for the long term because
it does transmit flu and other things
you know we have flu in our country that
kills on average thirty six thousand
people a year 36,000 people and you know
that's something that we're not talking
about but as of this moment we've lost
fifty possibly a little bit less than
fifty but probably fifty people and
we're gonna try and keep that number as
Louis Pasteur God is telling service
members and their families not to travel
domestically should all Americans follow
that same advice well you don't have to
travel I wouldn't do it if you don't
have to go we want this thing to end we
don't want a lot of people getting
infected we want it to end and end as
quickly as possible so far I think we've
done a fantastic job I really think that
the people behind me have not been given
the credit that they deserve because
they have done a fantastic job when you
see all these school closures when you
see the school closures are very
important but it causes a lot of
problems the bill that we signed
yesterday takes care a lot of those
problems with children staying at home
and the parents that work in the now we
take care of that issue with what we
passed last night none has to go through
the Senate I have to sign it but that
will happen but I'm now going back to
the White House you have great
professionals and
there's anything that comes up if
there's anything Thank You mr. president
I just wanted to follow up on that
are you considering other travel
restrictions
perhaps domestically in that regard to
engage specifically from certain areas
yes we are and we're working with the
states and we are considering other
restrictions yes Reuters is reporting
that you're gonna spend the European
travel the UK and Ireland on Monday is
that you're looking at a very seriously
yet because they've had a little bit of
activity unfortunately so we're gonna be
looking into that that we are actually
already have looked at it and that is
going to be announced if I could just
get a little clarity on your thinking on
this it's been a hallmark of your
presidency you're always going after the
Fed if you feel so strongly about it why
don't you dismiss the Chairman or do you
think you're powerless to do so no I
think I have the right to do that or the
right to remove him as chairman he's he
is so far made a lot of bad decisions in
my opinion we had this great and we will
soon have again because I think you can
have a tremendous bounce when this is
over I think there's a pent-up bounce
that's going to be tremendous I think
you saw that yesterday with the stock
market no I'm not happy with the Fed
because I think that they are following
that leading we should be leading I'm
not happy because if you look at the
central banks of other you know other
central banks largely they're lower than
us their rate and their equivalent of
the Fed rate is lower in some cases by
two points in some cases that's a lot in
some cases very substantially and I
thought that the Fed would be and should
be much more proactive as opposed to
following a Fed is following we have the
number one currency in the world by a
factor of many times as you know we have
the currency we have the power we have
by far the strong currency also you look
at the dollar the strength of the dollar
our Fed is not doing what they should be
doing we shouldn't have a Fed rate
that's higher than
our competitor nations you look at
Germany they're essentially under zero
they're negative there are many
countries negative Japan is negative
Germany's negative others are negative
and we're paying higher interest rates
and what I'd like to do is frankly
refinance our debt we could refinance
our debt very easily at a much lower
rate we have a we have some tremendous
opportunities right now but Jerome
Powell is not making it easy no I have
the right to remove I'm not doing that
no I'm not doing that I have the right
to also take him and put him in a
regular position to put somebody else in
charge and I haven't made any decisions
on that
[Music]